[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
Rett this week at the round table of
demm lighting it's a new
year
2024 but not really for us because we're
recording this in 2023 record the behind
the curtain right before we take our
break this thing can come out fresh at
the top of the year so happy New Year to
you but we are bisc in a mood to talk
about the year ahead yes we
are um I have some things that I just I
I want to put out there I guess a
resolution oh really yep I have some
deep fears and hopes oh gosh okay that
I'm looking forward to sharing with you
but at first I I wanted to say thank you
link good to say it
mean technically technically it was this
was all me but you played a significant
role in it so I'm just going to say
thank you you're welcome uh I left my
phone in your vehicle the other night uh
oh this is good because this is what I
want to talk about yeah we uh we we
spent some time together at the uh the
Wonka Premiere
Wonka I was dressed like I was dressed
like a fool it's a prequel I mean I
didn't know anything about it and here I
am like say this is a this is a prequel
isn't it this is going to be a prequel
it was well let me just say I learned
something you know uh I took what you
might call a fashion risk and I learned
that all you have to do is dress like a
piece of furniture to get lots of
compliments and it just feels mhm it
feels cheap I'm just going to say it
feels cheap it feels like this is what
it takes like literally to take
something that should be curtains or a
couch upholstery and just wear it
Loosely on your body as a suit and then
I but the number of people who stopped
me to compliment me I began to feel
stupid because I was like you do realize
that this is just fabric put into the
shape of a man that I am inside right
now I yeah but no one else is wearing
that right I guess that's what it is
anyway
um my
phone the case disintegrated and fell
off of my phone and so I'm going raw dog
on my phone have been for a number of
days here no no case no put it that way
and
uh these phones were not made to be
inside your pockets without cases
because they slide all over the place I
sat down at the movie premiere it fell
right on the floor immediately I didn't
real I did realize it but when I was
sitting in your car it fell out again
you left me a little deposit when I got
home after dropping you off I looked
over there and there was a nice little
phone turd you'd left in your seat and I
realized it not immediately I realized
it it several minutes into being at home
and I was like oh crap I think I left my
phone in Link's car uh call it my wife
called it I didn't hear it and I was
like I was probably still in the car and
then she called you and you had already
taken it inside well I tried to answer
your phone oh you did you don't know how
to answer my phone I couldn't do it I it
was too slick um but I had a decision to
make now you don't live too far from me
I hop SK skiping a jump as they might
say I could be at your house
in how many seconds if I wanted to 20 uh
two 200 seconds yeah i' say 180 seconds
180 seconds yeah and I thought when
Jesse called I was like she said well he
might just get in in the morning I was
like good cuz I was just going to tell
you I was leaving it out in front of the
sprinklers on the stoop I was going to
leave it on the stoop no need for you to
like come in for us to have another
exchange we had been we had seen each
other you know but I made a decision how
was what' you think of that Wonka you
want to talk about that some more I made
a decision to not retrieve my phone I
was glad now I immediately started
mapping out the rest of my evening mhm
yeah cuz there was quite a lot of
evening left we got home at like 7 o'cl
right and a lot and a lot of
morning and a whole night of sleep ahead
of me with no phone and I was like well
this complicates things I can't just be
on my phone all
night um yeah what what on Earth are you
going to do I'm not going to be able to
like what about my alarm I was like I'm
telling Jesse as we're going to bed I'm
like can you set an can you set an alarm
for 6:15 because I'm getting up at 6:15
tomorrow and she's like okay yeah and
and then I'm like oh I got my workout
planned and I I hook my my heart monitor
up to my you Bluetooth to my phone and
I'm not going to track it does it count
if you can't track your I feel so lost
exercise I kind of feel that way if I
can't track my exercise count data it
doesn't feel like it counts right but I
want to say thank you for having a car
have to have a phone left in because
spending an evening and a morning
without the
phone yes uh and
specifically pooping twice without the
phone has really opened things up for
me that's a gross way to now for those
of you who watch the GMM Marathon you
may have heard me talk about this well
you're stealing my thunder this was my
thing oh really yeah this is my thing
pooping yeah no I said pooping is your
thing my New Year's resolution I thought
pour and milk was your thing it it is my
New Year's resolution that I told you
was I am
not using my phone while on the toilet I
am I'm not going to do it I made that
decision and I told you that and then
you were like well yeah you know you had
my phone and oh okay so here it is but
it happened to me my idea well no I did
it before it was your idea as a natural
consequence of not having a phone was it
your resolution did you did you resolve
to not poop with your phone maybe you
can listen to some firsthand data from a
guy who's pooped twice without a phone
in the past week we can both have the
same resolution well I'm not saying it's
my resolution I'm just saying I've done
it it seems like you did it but it was
my idea well uh that's fine it wasn't my
idea I was forced into it so you're
doing my resolution yeah I going out I'm
a I'm a a resolution Scout does that
mean I don't have to do it no it's not
how it works I'm saying it's like
somebody saying I want to lose 10 pounds
this year and I'm like well I just did
ask me all the questions you need okay
all right so I've pooped twice so let me
tell you what I'm thinking and then I'm
going to ask you some questions to see
how it was okay it seems like it was
positive because you've been thanking me
nonstop yeah and I would like to thank
you for that okay thank you for thanking
me
ask away I'm a
pro I just don't need to be sitting on
the toilet longer well that's not a
question that's a statement but I agree
with it I don't it's just not it's not
good for it's not good for the roids
it's not good for my anatomy right I'll
put it I'll put it that way you really
should be on you should be on it should
be out and you should be up that's the
process and that's how it should work
and it's it's just an instinct it's like
oh I'm I'm not a pun I'm just sitting
there and I'm like well at least I can
be on my phone and then it it more than
doubles I mean on average the amount of
time and my body just can't take it my
body can't take it well that's fair can
I tell you the me and also the fact that
there's other stuff that I need that I
could be doing that don't that don't
that aren't on the toilet well see that
that that's a thing this is the thing
that I was thinking the entire time that
I was pooping without a phone and I was
like
wow this is what it used to
be this is what it was for so many years
it was just me a man on a toilet pooping
and that was enough for me it was enough
that I wasn't just hanging on to a tree
out in the woods and having to bury it
like an animal you know what I'm saying
like all of our ancestors it was a I was
a modern man sitting on a porcelain
throne relieving myself directly into
the city's pipes I mean I was already at
the peak of my existence as a person a
Civic hole right and then Along Came the
smartphone and screwed it up for me and
everyone else because now I'm like well
I'm sitting here here's an opportunity
for me to look into this window of Doom
yeah that is my phone to to try to keep
up with what's going on you know what's
going on I'm defecating that's the only
thing that needs to be going on right
now now and you need to be enjoying
it yeah and you need to be focused on it
yeah there's a lot you can learn from it
right uh you need to be not you don't
need to be examining your phone you need
to be examining your poop to see what
the consistency is to draw conclusions
about yourself and then you need to get
up and get on with your life now yeah so
I did that twice I
agree when am I going to work I don't
know you know it's like I feel like
that's where I do most of my best work
and I don't work on catching up on no I
don't do that messages I don't do that
it's all Leisure for me it's all Leisure
for me I don't do any work I'm just
being entertained but I do have this
intention when I walk in my bathroom
here's the thing there's this like
there's this nice little privacy pony
wall that basically is right there at
elbow Pony I don't have the pony I just
have the wall oh okay I'm the
pony okay sitting down on the toilet on
the other side of the wall and I can set
my phone right up there and then I can
but that's too close I'm just going to
pick it back up and keep using it you
know uh that's where I put it to to to
wrap things up you know when I don't
when I need my hands free sometimes it
takes two hands well why don't you get
one of those you should get a little one
of those little things that keeps you
where you can prop it up like a holster
so I can well like the things we used to
sell the popsocket things have you heard
what my resolution is oh saying if you
want to lean into it but you can watch a
whole maybe an episode of SciFi while
while you're sitting there I could you
shouldn't though that's not that's
against that's kind of the opposite of
what I'm okay so what are you going to
do with it I can't put it on the pony
wall now I could put it on the sink
because that requires standing up and
walking three steps or staying in a
seated position but waddling five
steps and then waddling backwards five
steps and sitting and then putting my
butt back on the seat why don't you just
I think that's far enough that like if I
develop a habit of whenever I walk into
the bathroom pooping time I put my phone
down by the sink and then I back up and
then I pull my pants down and then my
body knows my brain knows oh the pants
are look down there why would you
consider bra your pants were down
waddling to a place why would that even
be one of the options that you would go
through mind why is that even something
you
considered because if I'm on the toilet
and I and I hate myself for the decision
I've made if you haven't gotten rid of
your phone I've got to go that's how I
that's what I got to do to go get the
phone is waddle over there so I'm saying
I don't think the phone should enter the
bathroom at all I think there's a
holster on the outside of the bathroom
really yeah and it says no phones
allowed you know what it could be
like you know those hotel rooms that
when you go in and when you turn on
there's like a map F switch right there
you can't even turn the lights on
without putting the phone in a holster
you can't even turn you have to put your
key in a slot before any of the lights
come on is that how it works yeah yeah
lots of European hotels are this way I
think that you have to put your phone in
a holster before the water comes
Ono this is going to require a
plumber yeah can you make a holster that
my phone has to be in in order for the
water to turn on in my bathroom oh
what why man first of all no or I could
just talk to a doctor can you make a
holster that when I put my unless I put
my phone in it the poop won't come out
of my butt yeah that's not yeah I don't
think a daughter is going to do that for
you not the kind of that I know uh okay
well maybe it's just the how about you
just put the phone outside of the
bathroom we need some sort of reward
like when I put my phone it did you
experience enough of a reward tell me
that because I feel like we need to
brainstorm when you put your phone in
the slot it like plays this
relaxing poop
inducing uh
track I I mean she trying to go for a
pavlovian thing like you want a little
biscuit that pops out or something like
yeah a little biscuit an audio
biscuit what's something an ear biscuit
if you will something that makes you
something that has a laxative effect I
don't need that oh you're doing okay me
too I need more fiber
okay it gives you a little dollop of
fiber you put your phone in a little
slot and a little fiber pill comes out
little chewable a gummy a gummy now I'll
go for a gummy cuz that feels like a
treat but it's not it's not a bad gummy
it's a good gummy well why
do mhm why
not can't you just put some sort of like
connection between your toilet and the
phone that it deactivates that's a smart
toilet all I've got a damn smart toilet
it's got It's got Jets it's got fans
it's got heaters I have the best I
that's why I sit on the toilet so long I
have a proposal there's so many great
things about it but certainly you could
connect the you could dis your toilet
could disable your phone I'm going to go
a step further link because the thing
that not having my phone while pooping
twice and again you got to remember I
didn't have a phone at all for at least
12 hours it was it was a dark time okay
yeah that's tough man I'm glad you made
it the thing that really hit me was the
late evening
hours and the early morning hours okay
and so the late evening hours of course
it was there's no phone in your in your
bed which I try to not do that but I'm
not super disciplined at like not
getting on social media after 7 o'cl
I'll go through phases where I'm good at
that but because I have to set my alarm
and I like to have my phone next to me
on the bedside table in case something
goes down sure it's it's my window to
the world you need to talk to me about
something you my my mom needs to tell me
something whatever you
know it's the it's the way to get in
touch with
me and then and because it's my alarm
it's there in the morning so it's in
order to it's really a flawed system and
I know you're if you've already made
these choices in your life you probably
see all the the the holes that we have
yet to fill the fact that I have to
reach and actually touch my phone the
first action that I have to take is to
turn my alarm off I have to touch the
screen the first physical action of my
day is to touch this evil Satan box mhm
and and you love it and I so the clear
path around that is an alarm clock what
I'm proposing to you my friend is to up
the antie on your resolution and I'll
join you in this no phones in the
bedroom uh
uh-uh I don't have a problem well I get
I don't get on my phone into bed
what I don't about I'm better than you
in way what about what okay I I I noce
it I get so excited about going to sleep
I mean it's like oh I'm here can't wait
for my eyes to close wo here it is when
do you here it is going to sleep well
you don't look at the phone in the
morning well it it the and the alarm is
a gentle wakeup that I use that that I
don't like alarming alarm but you have
but okay maybe you don't have maybe you
don't have the problem that I
do I have the option of like oh like
this news I mean I don't have any news
apps that are currently like giving me
updates but it might be that like
there's a work rated thing or something
like how do I get so I want to have a
way that people can get in touch with me
like break through well that I mean no
without the phone without the the iPhone
has all that stuff well no I currently
don't like you
can't this crazy news thing is happening
like I don't get any notifications about
news anymore but like the health there's
like this all like the health and
well-being stuff like all of that's in
there dude you can use that stuff
but okay let's say it's like do y'all
use any of that any of the phone limits
mhm yes so how does it work cuz I'm
telling him it's all built in there you
just set the downtime and then um
there's like a thing where if certain
numbers call it can get through I think
right but does it does it keep you from
going on apps like Instagram after a
certain amount of time you can do that
yeah it adds um then you can immediately
override it if you want to I tried that
you can immediately override it I'm
addicted to the phone it adds an extra
step of oh you're seeing that it's like
do you really want to click back in and
you have to do an extra click be like
yes I'm making this decision yeah yeah
yeah and it's called downtime during
downtime only apps that you choose to
allow and phone calls will be available
turn on downtime until tomorrow I have
that I have it scheduled I do it but
what I'm saying is is that when I wake
up downtime's over maybe I could extend
downtime but still I might be like uh
how's that video doing or uh let me see
your um your your let's compare
uh hold on now activity oh don't you no
I'm not trying to say I'm better than
you trying to embarrass me now you know
I'm on the phone you're on the phone so
much I I'm just saying I I hate the
phone so much that like I
don't you know I've got my issues I'm
only going to tell you if I uh um so if
you go to screen
time my daily
average see all app and website activ
ity my daily
average is 3 hours and 51
minutes well and it was 3 hours and 35
minutes until I until I showed up here
and all of a sudden it changed to 51 it
was well mine this
week this week is 2 hours 21 minutes but
last week mine was four and a half
hours okay see so there you go and most
of it's gray what is the gray
stuff Instagram
no yeah
Spotify Spotify is a big one that that's
that shouldn't count no I want to I want
to say every single day I use a workout
app see because it says productivity
productivity is is my number one so on
average this morning see you're I'm more
than you 52 minutes of
productivity No 41 minutes of health and
fitness I don't know 54 minutes of
social this was a mistake I'm getting
I'm we're getting kind of bogged
down let's forget about it let's go back
to your thing you're not going to have
your phone in your bedroom and I'm not
going to have it in the bathroom it's
that simple I want to support you in
that yeah but I want to know like you
you can get excited about a new how do I
find a way for people to get through to
me that's not through my phone your
wife's phone no she
needs we need to be off the grid Off the
Grid except for like there some way that
people can break through there surely
there's like an alarm
clock an alarm clock that exists that is
like Bluetooth connected to your phone
and a certain kind of thing like a call
from Mom can get through to the alarm
clock and it makes a weird noise like
it's like your mom saying red it's me
your mom and it's and it's through the
alarm clock and then I know oh she's
calling me I'm going to go get my
phone can't this technology
exist this is actually leading very hard
into the into my hopes and fears for the
for the year I I I'm I'm about to
venture into just talking about it
because it's spilling
over uh well hold your horses but I I
think bre we should wait let's take a
breath look you're you're you're worked
up I am 2024 why are you so worked up
we're not even actually in the year yet
oh man but you don't understand what's
going to happen that's why you got to
keep it simple man that's why I'm trying
to get my damn room
man the phone's out I'm I am like inside
my bedroom set the downtime I want to go
17th century inside my bedroom there's
no lights it's all
candles you know what I'm saying chamber
pot chamber pot I I don't even have
Plumbing can I go 16th century in my
bedroom well yeah I mean everything
except the chest you're going to want
antibiotics I'm just going to go ahead
and tell you well okay yeah I mean I got
to figure out where I'm drawing the line
here but I'm saying
technologically I go
into that part of my house and it's like
I've stepped back in
time that's what I want put the phone
across the room it's that simple and
then set up your downtime where it if
you emergency numbers can break through
and then you have to get up and get out
of bed and go over there and get it and
and I put it in a box that has a series
of locks and that well this also has
your alarm clock on it that I have to
solve every night you have to get out of
bed to to deactivate your alarm clock on
your phone which makes you not snooze I
don't I'm not a snoozer okay you're not
AO okay I'm not a snoozer I learned that
the hard way it's simple as that
okay it's a holster you have a holster
just on the outside of your bedroom I
have a holster just on the outside of my
bathroom okay you're going to do great
why are you talking to me like this I
just I'm trying to talk you down a
little bit you're worked up you've gone
medieval on our ass yeah well no I'm
gone like
Victorian okay I'm going all the way
back to the 10th Century or whatever
this is a good idea this is a good idea
I'm going to get you a phone
slot for your
resolution I I think I could have set it
on the set it on the the dresser across
the room and in on the charger because
you still want I got a new phone coming
by the way I don't want to talk about it
I'm just saying I got a new one this
really goes against everything I'm going
to be so freaking excited about this new
phone you know the latest to greatest
put the charger go ahead and when you're
in your right frame of mind take the
charger you got mag safe put the yes put
the charger on the other side of your
bedroom okay and then I'm going the
decision is made yeah yeah because then
do you want to have a phone the next day
well it's got to charge and I think
maybe I get something installed that if
I try to bring the phone into the bed it
begins to admit this really high pitched
noise that
like like we like everybody in the whole
family has to cover their ears and bleed
they bleed a little
bit don't don't punish anybody else for
your I got that from a a movie I
recently
watched I feel like which I recommend I
feel like this is plenty of New Year's
resolution yeah yeah yeah don't I've got
just more like what I've got is sort of
like Dread SL
hope and I you know what I'm going to be
lighter I'm going to get even lighter
mentally I'm going to bring it down in
2024 I don't want to do that I don't
want you to bring me down no actually I
think I might lift you up I think you
might get equ equally excited and
terrified at the same time all right
before we get to it I want I want to
share with you the some of the best news
of the year for us and hopefully it's
good news for you too we are going on
tour again the Good Mythical tour is
happening this summer and let let's read
the let's read the dates we're it's good
mythical morning the
show revamped as a live and interactive
stage
performance uh it's it's a lot of fun
it's like it's freewheeling it's
tailored to each City and location we're
going to uh telling the cities right
well I don't currently have them written
down right here on on this particular ad
and I don't want to start trying to
remember them from from uh from memory
Los Angeles okay that's one of them
don't start
don't what's going to happen is you're
going to M you're going to miss one or
you're going to add one that's not true
and it's only going to all up for we're
going to add it we're going to edit it
in right here because it's that
important but right now we're just going
to say that it's if you're a second or
third degree member of the mythical
Society you get access to by tickets
including VIP tickets two days early
those tickets go on sell Wednesday
January 10th at 10:00 a.m. local time to
to wherever you are okay limited number
of VIP tickets and total tickets in each
place so uh that's a that's a great way
to get the leg up general sales uh begin
on
Friday uh January 12th at 10:00 a.m.
local time Good Mythical tour.com to
find out where we're going uh this June
so that you can come see us come see us
it's going to be so much fun we're
bringing crew members with us do we have
the cities yes June and the the end of
May it starts at the end of May Los
Angeles yes starts in Los Angeles then
we go to Nashville Tennessee St Louis
Chicago Columbus Ohio Atlanta Raleigh DC
and Philadelphia boom that's nine cities
I'm excited uh get in where you fit
in very excited fly to the closest place
it's going to be worth it to see it was
great seeing y'all at mythicon but you
know what we didn't see enough of y'all
at mythicon because it's just one place
right so we want to see more of y'all uh
we're bringing it closer Good Mythical
tour earbiscuits is supported by indeed
we're driven by the search for better
but when it comes to hiring the best way
to search for a candidate isn't to
search it's to match with indeed ditch
the busy work use indeed for scheduling
screening and messaging so you can
connect with candidates faster and
indeed does it just help you hire faster
93% of employees agree indeed delivers
the highest quality matches compared to
other job sites according to a recent
indeed survey it's hard to hire people I
mean and and just the logistics and the
time it takes to get through all of that
can wear you down to the point where you
might decide you know what I'm just
going to do it myself you start to think
things like that we've been there in the
past right merging over 140 million
qualifications and preferences every day
inde Deeds matching engine is constantly
learning from your preferences so the
more you use indeed the better it gets
join more than three and a half million
businesses worldwide that use indeed to
hire great Talent fast you can get a $75
sponsored job credit to get your jobs
more visibility at
indeed.com just go to indie.com with an
S right now and support ear Biscuits by
saying you heard about indeed right here
indeed.com terms and conditions apply
need to hire you need indeed ear biscuit
is supported by Rosetta Stone you know
learning language is difficult um there
needs to be a new way than than the way
that we did it in high school cuz I
ain't going back to that you don't want
Miss Slaughter to teach you anymore I
liked her a lot but I didn't really
retain a lot in comes Rosetta Stone the
most trusted language learning program
available on desktop or as an app and
that truly immerses you in the language
you want to learn they've used trusted
experts for 30 years with millions of
users in 25 languages offered some of
which include Spanish French German
Korean Chinese Japanese Dutch and Arabic
plus it's built for fast language
acquisition it has an intuitive process
so you can pick up a language naturally
first with words then phrases then
sentences and the built-in true accent
feature gives you feedback on your
pronunciation so you can learn to speak
like a pro Rosetta Stone is an amazing
value a lifetime membership has all 25
languages for any and all trips or
language needs in your life a $399
program but with our code you can get it
for just
$199 don't put off learning that
language there's no better time than
right now to get started for a very
limited time you can get Rosetta Stone's
lifetime membership for 50% off that's
50% off for unlimited access to 25
language courses for the rest of your
life redeem your 50% off at
rosettastone.com
ear
today Jamie I feel so good to hear and
so many
voicemails um saying that people have
peed in the bed and so I just wanted to
before you get into your existential
future crisis okay I just wanted to go
on record and say thank you for your
voicemails um I am not
alone y there's a few that stood
out and I'd like to just process those
quickly all right let's here we
go hi R link this is embarrassing that
this is my claim to fame so to speak but
um I'm just listening to the most recent
episode about link wedding the bed and I
had to chime in that I have also
experienced adult bed wedding um and
like red I also was a kid bed W and I
also had the mattress cover and so I
know what it feels like it's not fun
it's shameful but I grew out of it and
everything has been fine until this fall
I wet the bed twice the first time I was
dreaming that I was peeing like in a
toilet and then woke up and was like
[__] I'm actually peeing but then like a
week later it happened again and I
wasn't dreaming so then I went to the
doctor CU I kind of got freaked out and
they basically told me that my body was
so stressed that I just slept really
hard hey guys
so on the topic of adult bed wedding my
father um he was probably in his late
50s at the time he had a he was having a
really intense dream he had just retired
and he hated his boss snuck into his
boss's office and was going to pee like
either in his trash can or on his desk I
guess the trash can wouldn't make sense
he's going to like pee on his desk right
and he said that he woke up as he
started to do it in the dream because he
was starting to pee in real life so hey
R and Link I'm not even done listening
to your episode but I had to call in and
tell you about my bed wedding story so I
was a bed wer way too late I think I
stopped waiting the bed when I was 10
years old and to make matters worse I
slept right in between my mom and my dad
so I peed on them quite often I put that
hasn't happened in a long time but maybe
a year or two ago I woke up in the
middle of the night and my underwear was
all wet and I I peed myself as a fully
grown adult I'm almost 30 years old see
I feel so much better I don't feel alone
thank you for the voicemails I have not
peed my bed or anybody else's bed are
you thinking about it still um you know
what not really and I don't think when
you go to your mom's house next time
it'll come back think about it again I
um am I don't think I was that stressed
I just think I was super hydrated
because I'm really good at that and if
it were to keep happening I'd probably
stop drinking so much water before I go
to bed but I I don't I don't know how
you like that's the thing the fact that
you don't have to get up and pee in the
middle of the night when you drink a lot
of water right before you go to bed and
as you get older as a guy you're you
know they say it's inevitable you get to
a certain Agee and have to get up and
pee I wake up in order to drink water in
the middle of the night like I just wake
up thirsty like and I just reach over I
grab my water and I just keep drink it I
mean that's going to have to be altered
um you're not going to be able to but
sustain I'm not going to the doctor of
course I'm stressed but I don't think
that's what it was I think it was just a
oneoff it was a one-off unless it
happens again yep and then we'll have to
revisit have a pattern I don't have a
boss or former boss that I want to pee
on cuz I don't have a boss pretty great
right you know so I don't have anybody
that I want to pee on in that way well
what way do you want to pee on so oh
it's not I didn't mean to
imply I mean I haven't tried that no I I
don't uh I mean I'm listen nothing
against you if you're into it but I
haven't tried it yeah I like U I like
more of the pristine shower maybe in my
17th century
bathroom without Plumbing we'll try
we'll try that we got no phones in there
we got to start mixing it up a little
bit have you peed on yourself for fun no
no I'm going back to the original
question since we last talked about it I
mean I just don't want you to fly under
the radar here the moment you pee I'll
let yourself you better let me know I
would let CU you didn't last time um you
didn't yeah I don't think that that was
I don't think that I think that happened
when we
were not making so many episodes about
personal things okay are you I'm happy
to tell you about it
and you know what people call in it
makes me think if if you want to
commiserate about the use of the phone
on the toilet or if you have an answer
if you've cracked the code on Rhett's
problem in the bed or mine on the toilet
yeah call us 1888 earpod one are you
asking for me to hold you accountable to
that resolution
resolution uh yeah I'm asking you to ask
me about it you're not going to you're
not going to take it to the bathroom and
I'm going to put it across the room mhm
in the bedroom yeah you go which also
means I'm not going to have it on the so
I'm doing your resolution plus oh yeah
yep you're outdoing me if you can
achieve it what are you going to do
downstairs when you got to take a little
poopy
downstairs I just I I'll put it away or
I I just want I'll I simply won't pull
it out of my pocket good I will be an
adult just going to be sitting there
your pants all rolled up at the bottom
of the your feet yeah things flashing
down there you getting little messages
it's the whole world the whole world is
on the other side of that screen I down
there at my
ankle which brings me
to my hopes and fears link um now I want
to talk about this precisely
because I know that there is a large
swath of people who don't want to hear
about it so I'm actually talking about
that phenomenon if you're just like oh
no he's gonna start talking about AI
sounds like you're going
to I'm not lecturing anybody
um I think I just breathed in a
hair went right down well you I mean you
also like you breathe in 2.3 spiders a
year too so don't worry about it
um I just kind of want to take stock of
where we're at because with
just where technolog is going right now
and what may be about to happen this
year and what I think we're opening up
what kind of started we're talking about
the AI box again you're opening your
yeah but I want to I know I talked about
people to tune out right I precisely if
now if you're the kind of person who's
like you're into this and you're
thinking about it then I don't have to
tell you to stick around sure but if
you're the kind of person who's like I
don't want to think about it I don't
want to talk about it I don't want to
hear anyone talk about it yeah I'm going
to go get on the toilet right now just
don't check out because this is actually
about that that's that's precisely the
conversation I want to have because let
me just tell you I don't want to talk
about it either and I don't want to
think about it and I'll also premise all
of this with saying I don't know what
I'm talking about I'm not a good source
for any of this so I'm not like talking
about this in a way to inform you
because don't say that I don't think you
should say that there's so many people
who could inform you in an informed way
I'm just talking about it as a fellow
citizen who is navigating the
technological shift that has begun and
will
continue and it's just commiserating but
also a little hopeful just just go for
it uh but I just wanted people know I'm
not going to be like oh I know about
this and I know about that because I
really it's the lack of what I know
about it is actually the thing that
scares me the most
so the way that 2023 unfolded for me and
a lot of you I assume is that it was the
first time you had ever really seriously
thought about artificial intelligence
Beyond just like hearing somebody talk
about it in a video here or there right
because there was this new product of
chat GPT that some people in your family
or like that one dude that you know like
started using it right and would be like
Oh I'm using it for this and I'm using
it for that and I'm using it for this
and you were like maybe I'll go and
check it out or maybe I'll watch watch a
little video about it or maybe you like
I'm not interested I don't want anything
to do with this and then it kind of
seems like from your perspective people
kind of quit talking about it as much
right because you because you stepped
out of the conversation and you were
kind of like I maybe that's nothing's
going to happen with that maybe not
maybe it's not really a thing maybe
maybe it's just a thing that people
talked about and then we're going to
kind of go back to normal okay
right um that is not what is happening
guys that is not what is
happening the shift that we are on the
precipice of experiencing as a culture
as a species
species is more significant than any
shift we have ever
experienced ever
experienced bigger than the internet
bigger than the internet bigger than the
Industrial Revolution bigger than
agriculture
pterodactyls or maybe as big as like
Civilization Maybe as big as like
agriculture printing we're talking about
like the major shifts in the history of
humanity and internet we're in we're in
a crazy time because like we live
through like the information age and
like the internet and now we're like
living through the beginning
of what artificial intelligence is going
how it's going to change us and like
again I'm not going to get into like
well this is going to happen and this is
going to happen and like general
intelligence and all this stuff because
yes is there's this potential
potentiality that will happen which
artificial general intelligence will
happen sooner than anyone is
expecting and at that point all bets are
off where this is going we have
absolutely no idea I'm not talking about
that scenario of like either the the
world is going to become a Utopia or the
world we're all going to die like those
are basically the only two options if
general intelligence happens I'm not
talking about that I'm just talking
about the continuation of what has
started with chat
GPT now I showed you or you I told you
about it and then you watched it and if
you haven't watched it I think it's
important that you do watch it to kind
of just begin
to grasp a little bit about what might
just the capabilities if you watch that
Google Gemini presentation they
basically launched their own AI product
built from the ground up in a that was
built in a different way then chat GPT
called that it was
multimodal um in how like it could use
audio it could use text input it could
use video or picture input it can use
different types of input and it's all
with in this robust system from the
ground up that chat
GPT G started out as started out as just
you now can like dolly is like you know
image generator is kind of built into
chat gbt and you can't upload pictures
and that now and that kind of thing but
it but the presentation but it's a
completely
parallel product to chat GPT it's not
something that like was built and then
branched off is was my impression oh
yeah it's a completely yeah the the the
team working on it Google is a
completely different team and they
basically
leapfrogged uh chat gbt in a number of
different important like measurements or
whatever right but here's the thing
there's a point at which like if you
think about the internet there's a there
was the there was the the the
conversation where people like our
friend Mike understood the internet and
maybe even used the internet way before
all of us understood the internet right
and what ends up happening is the way
that technology gets introduced
to the average person the
consumer is when the interface becomes
simplistic enough so that you can
incorporate it into your everyday life
right so you had people who were using
computers back in the 60s right and they
were like taking pieces of paper that
had dots on them and they were like
putting the thing no no normal person
understood what the hell that was and
how that worked right but it wasn't
until all of a sudden these machines
showed up with a screen and there was
like a f file folder all this stuff that
isn't anything it's just an interface
for you to be able to un to interact
with the computer and to use the power
of the computer to your advantage as a
normal person right a gooey and so right
now we're at this place where like for
the past few years and kind of moving
2023 was the beginning of like more
quote unquote normal people who aren't
like computer experts beginning to use
chat GPT or AI on a more regular basis
and also AI being incorporated into all
these things that you're already using
yeah like talented High School essayists
exactly so Chad so Jim and I um and
again this is not I I'm there's if you
want to understand it listen to somebody
else so I'm you know it's like I don't
understand it I'm just this consumer who
doesn't understand how any of it works
who's just seeing the technology being
demonstrated and it's beginning to dawn
on me how much my existence is about to
change and so if you watch that Gemini
presentation you'll see essentially
they're kind of showing this webcam
things they're drawing on it they're
showing it different things and they're
interacting and asking it questions and
it's answering and making observations
and essentially we were very very
quickly getting to the point where every
single person has access to the smartest
person in the world I'm going to try to
make an analogy here right so like how
would your life change if everywhere you
went someone tagged along with you and
it was the smartest person who ever
lived and they were just with you all
the time they had access to every single
piece of information that had ever
existed and they could uh they could
quantify anything they could explain
anything they could help you understand
anything they could show you how to make
a recipe they could constantly offer
input into every single thing that you
experience in life and they are with you
at all times and you might say one might
say well isn't that just like having
access to the internet like what what we
talked about like having the phone in
the palm of your hand you have access to
all this
information but it's different it's it's
actually like having a person tag along
with you who then has access to
everything on the internet in a way that
they
can uh synthesize it right because the
thing is is that yes there are there are
people who know how to use the tools of
the internet in a really sophisticated
way but that's not that's not most
people most people are like uh I know
how to Google something I know how to
ask the internet a question I know how
to get directions for something I might
be able to pull up a recipe right but
you're there's so many steps that are
happening between you having that
thought and then you going and inputting
this information in that all those steps
and that interface is changing so
quickly
that you know how you like we talking
about pooping earlier pooping without a
phone yeah were and then pooping with a
phone and like how that experience is
different and if you were to show
yourself from 20 years ago you sitting
there [__] and looking at this
little TV you would have been like what
the hell Star Trek like that is we're
about to to move well beyond that
because well well there's a video that I
watched uh that kind of explains like
the new internet and generative AI which
is essentially that
like and you can kind of see this in the
Gemini presentation right where the guy
is trying to get the trying to get
Gemini to help him plan a birthday party
for his daughter and the way that the
computer decides to generate these ideas
is by creating a website essentially
like generating this
interface and after asking him a series
of questions yeah you tell you tell it
what your daughter likes and like what
she's into and then it gives you some
options and then you kind of pick one of
those options and then it iterates on
that and then it tells you these are
some cupcakes you can make and we're and
in not too distant the
future you that smartest person in the
world will not just be on an interface
that you hear and see like that's the
next stage is like you know everybody's
concerned like it's funny how we make so
much fun of those Ray bands those meta
Ray bands and everybody's like oh this
is crazy this is this violation of
privacy because like you could be
filming like people are thinking about
it on ju just the tip of the iceberg
right now but the fact is is that we're
all going to have some kind of
observational interface that is take
that that is on us because that's going
to be the observational interface for
the smartest person in the room that is
always with you like if you're sitting
down to make a
recipe it's going to look down and see
what you're doing and tell you when like
in that same thing it's like when do I
turn the omelet over
now and I think that there's you know
again we in some senses this is like
Katie kurick and Brian G Bryant Gumble
talking about the internet in that
famous clip where they had no idea what
the internet was that's what me talking
about this is going to look like in the
future but that's why I'm not saying
much cuz you look stupid I I'm just it's
all beginning to kind of register with
me like we were at our friend in L's
house and he had those metag glasses and
like we put them on and like we recorded
an interaction and then uh he played it
back audio-wise and it has this spatial
audio that only the person wearing the
glasses is hearing so like he was over
here and Link was over here and when
they recorded this thing and then I put
him back on and played it back and Link
was over here and he was over here it
was like it recreated that moment and I
was like all I need is some sort of
little arvr interface that's built into
this to fully recreate the visual
experience along with the audio
experience and it's just all beginning
to stack up really really quickly and
all these companies are competing and I
and I'm also watching these experts talk
about it and talking about how yes we're
all talking about safeguards and slowing
it down and making sure that it doesn't
destroy us and all this and those are
the great intentions behind all that but
it seems to me that the people who
really know what they're talking about
in a way that I can't even really
comprehend cuz they're way smarter than
me
are saying that we really can't do
anything to stop it at this point with
the Pandora's Box has been opened and
the only thing controlling the outcome
is the laws of physics okay it's not our
intentions of what we will do with
this and I'm just having a little bit of
a difficult time accepting that and
processing that and living with that
because things are about to change so
and there's another there's it's
happening in so many different areas but
like one fascinating thing in the area
of medicine right so deep mind has been
working on Alpha fold which is
essentially AI as it applies to uh
analyzing organic structure so protein
folding is basically how everything
organic is made
right and I don't they're very far along
on this process and I don't know how
they're very close to essentially being
able to simulate at any organic process
to basically simulate any body like to
create an exact model of me in a in a
digital world where then all it takes is
enough computing power and enough
information and we can get to a place
where we know every single thing about
the way the Body Works physically and
the way that any chemical would interact
with it and so you can begin to
understand the applications for medicine
and you can be like well if you give
this stuff enough information and it
gets sophisticated enough even without
assuming sort of general intelligence
it'll be able to cure any disease it'll
be able to solve any problem if we're
like well what do we do about climate
change like what do we actually do like
what kind of Technology can be developed
Material Science like you know there was
that recent breakthrough we thought we
had that breakthrough this year where
they had created the superc conducting
metal in Korea and everybody was like
this changes everything and we're going
to have unlimited energy and all this
stuff
and it was like well maybe it was an
accident maybe it wasn't really created
in that
way these computers are going to be able
to very
quickly in a in a simulation create all
kinds of materials that then can be
applied to the real world so you could
take a million of the smartest
scientists who ever lived and be like
develop all these materials and we're
going to give you a million years to
develop these things what could they
come up with with unlimited resour
ources well if you could simulate that
process inside of a computer with enough
computing power all those problems can
be you see where all this is going I
don't know when we're going to get there
but like that's the thing that's about
that's the thing that's beginning to
happen the accelerating nature of it all
is and we just we're not we have we're
not ready yeah over this next year it is
going to there the the people who seem
to know are saying that it's going to
this is going to be the year where that
it's going to be dramatic changes well
it's my understanding is that it's the
year where the progress in these models
and these
systems like passes a a threshold now
first of all that threshold could
legitimately be like self-enhancing
general
intelligence um which at that point when
anybody starts talking about that I just
be I don't like at that point I just I
can't keep up I can't keep up with all
the things that could happen at that
point because there's this
self-modifying
ability
for a model to create a better model of
itself to create a better model of
itself you know very very quickly and
then all these questions of like what do
you again people are saying you can't
really you can't really stop it I mean
Neil degrass Tyson says you just unplug
the computer but my understanding is
it's not that simple well I think you
know I start to think of it
interpersonally and how we were talking
about it the other day in terms of the
ai's ability to
emulate relational
Dynamics like you can very
easily imagine having an AI in your ear
and having a conversation with somebody
and it's listening and saying okay my
objective is I'm on a first date and I
want to win this person over and I want
to learn things about them and I also
want to take my Tendencies into account
and my flaws and the way that I interact
with people these are some things that
I've observed about myself maybe the AI
has been in all of my therapy sessions
for the past year and now can you apply
everything you know about me in my ear
while I'm on this date or while I'm
giving this while I'm in this board
meeting or doing whatever I'm doing and
then so it's just like I'm having this
interpersonal interaction let's say it's
romantic and then you're being fed it's
like having an
earpiece like Ellen degenerous is
telling you what to say but this per and
the advice is like great because it's
processed everything about you and
remembering I mean the therapy part of
it just started to get to me because I'm
like well first of
all well let me finish my first thought
and then so you're talking to that
person and then all of a sudden they
also have it and then we were talking
about the the committee example of well
my AI is telling me Oh yeah it's it it
was her birthday so you need to ask her
about that and you need to you should
apologize for not getting a gift even
though I told you to get one and then
she's like well you know he's
apologizing the AI is telling her and
then the a maybe the AI is connected and
it's just like so the whole conversation
becomes are you saying are you speaking
your mind or you speaking the ai's mind
cuz I'm just speaking the ai's mind
trying to get my way and what I'm saying
is that in a generation there will not
be a distinction is my guess right and
we have to figure out how let's break
down that because it might have been
that example might have been hard to
follow so let right now here this is the
way things might work right you might
have and and I know I've got people who
do this
because there are okay the the simple
version of this is like there's a
reminder on your phone to text someone
when it's their birthday right yeah a
lot of people already have that well the
next step is you have a reminder on not
a reminder on your phone automated you
have an automated text that is sent to
someone on their birthday well think
about they on their side they have an
automatic
reply to you sending an automatic
birthday wish to them right right fast
forward to the future a little a little
bit so that you essentially have a proxy
that can communicate your desires right
now it just might be like you send a
good you know you get an email and
Google reads the email and it gives you
three autor responses that you can just
click on right because it's reading the
email it knows what it says and if you
give the the computers access to every
email that you've ever sent everything
that you've ever said everything that
you are saying because it's all being
recorded again I'm not saying yes I'm
pushing all the Privacy things aside
because because yes that's going to slow
things down but I'm saying it's a very
small hurdle that culturally we will end
up just probably passing over so you can
see how this gets to a place where okay
I've got a proxy of myself that is based
on all everything that's true about me
and it's really really smart and you
could have a conversation a text
conversation even a phone conversation
with that proxy of me and it would be
like
99.9% accurate to how I would interact
with you so now my proxy is interacting
with your proxy and maybe we are
conducting a our proxies are conducting
a relationship and your proxy caught up
with my proxy and knows everything that
I did last year and kind of is like and
it wasn't a conversation it was just an
ex instant exchange of information but
now we come back to the organic brains
of me finally getting together with my
friend and it all started with just a
birthday text but now our proxies that
have access to all our information have
exchanged all this information and then
right before we meet our proxies
communicate everything that we need to
know in order to be ready to have the
real interaction it's just like well
that's why you better be in my ear cuz I
ain't going to remember at all yeah just
tell me it right when I need it and so
then you're like well that's not a real
relationship well that's kind of like
saying you use the
calculator that's not real math you know
like if you didn't calculate the tip
without the calculator it's not real I
know it's a little bit different because
it wasn't the actual conducting of the
relationship but I'm saying that that's
probably the slippery slope that we will
get to and and the dating example is
like okay if this girl that I am
interested in has opted into the system
so that her information is in the system
and her proxy exists so now I can put on
my little VR headset which is probably
just an arvr thing that's built into a
regular pair of glasses that I wear
every day and I can be like tonight I
want to go on a date with Laura that I'm
going to be going out on a date with on
Friday or you know what I'm gonna start
two weeks ahead of time and every single
night I'm gonna go out on a date with
Laura's
proxy and her proxy is completely
representative of exactly who she is and
so by the time the real date rolls
around and by the way she's been doing
the same thing with my proxy yeah and so
we have the DAT one of you is going to
decide that it ain't worth it right and
I might decide I don't want and talk you
think that looking at someone's dating
profile and swiping left or right is how
you're going to be making a decision no
you're going to have a threedimensional
audiovisual experience with this person
to decide whether or not you want to go
on an actual you're going to go on a
fake date with somebody before you go on
a real date with them I think you'll
eventually this isn't Star Trek this is
like 10 years from now you'll just be
told yep oh exactly she's the one trust
me trust me so you see how quickly all
this stuff starts happening and like how
quickly it it begin and by the way she's
not real it begins to make things seem
absolutely meaningless because I assume
if you're like me and Link I assuming
here you start hearing about this and it
creeps you the [__] out right you're
like I don't want to live in a world
where that's the case so what I'm saying
is is that if we're not going to live in
that
world there's well probably what's going
to happen is because it's an option and
some people can do it some people will
do it sure and we'll probably have two
class passes right or two like types of
people we'll have the people who are
tapped in and the people who are tapped
out and the people who are Tapped Out
are going to be like I live off the grid
I I've I don't even have a phone I we we
use wood for our fires or whatever I
think they would they would still just
be using the internet and stuff they'd
be using a
simulation of what the internet was and
what they don't know is that it's all
being run by the everybody who's in and
then just the AI if you go another few
years further into the future Beyond
these
proxies and now they really begin to
perfect the interface between these
digital systems and the physical world
so basically being able to take this
incred the smartest person's brain in
the world and put it into a robot that
actually has dexterity and has the
ability to interact with the with the
world in a meaningful way and now you've
got it literally is a robot that's in
your house or the follows you around and
so when you
say I plan my daughter's birthday don't
just plan my daughter's birthday make
everything for my daughter's birthday
buy the gifts make the cupcakes 3D print
the cupcakes so when we show up on
Saturday you've just done everything for
us and we didn't even have to tell you
anything because you've been listening
this whole time and you already made the
decision about what she would like
anyway you're you're better at it than
me now this obviously begins to remove
the Human Experience from life because
well I want to know what my daughter
wants and I want to be able to well we
want to make the cupcakes CU making the
cupcakes is fun I'm not saying this is
good or great or better I it's
probably definitively worse but I'm just
saying this is the inevitable place that
the technology could
lead because all of this stuff is
becoming possible to have this thing
that is observing the world interacting
with the world and an in ENT way that is
more intelligent than you like you're
still laughing at the funny pictures and
the fact that it makes a AI image with
two AR three arms or something like that
like that's going that's moving we're
moving beyond that so quickly and like I
even the way that we do it on GMM when
we do the AI generated episodes it's
like and we're kind of making fun of the
fact that it's so bad at understanding
what's going on with this that's just a
very that's a function of time
before okay predict the next year of
Good Mythical Morning episodes and it
will actually do a really good job of do
of doing it and it won't do it in a
stupid like uninformed way it'll do it
in a perfectly informed way how in are
you to this and let me ask it this way
it going back to the phone in the
bedroom
resolution are you would you be willing
to say AI that I have a relationship
with are you I want you to hold me
accountable to to this
and help me help me achieve the better
version of myself by not using my phone
when I'm going to bed at night and when
I'm
pooping if I follow the pattern that
I've already followed thus far it's you
you already asking for it use the
technology to my own benefit and like
you
said if I've trained the AI for it to
actually be to benefit and I asked the
AI hey could you plan my birthday party
or could could I go on a date with uh
fake Lura tonight because I'm going on a
date with her on Friday if it's actually
programmed to my benefit as a human that
is still just this biological thing
that's just based on all these years of
evolution if it's smart and has my best
interest in mind it'll be like you know
what I don't think you should do a fake
date because that's going to take the
joy out of the discovery and the
spontane that you will experience with
just going on a date with Laura because
here's the thing you're not a machine
you're a man and uh you can only you
need to operate within the limitations
of your existing physical architecture
and your brain and what it actually is
and it's not great to enhance the
experience in all these ways but here's
what we can do we can make sure that you
don't get
cancer right enough people will do that
that it'll be it'll be something that
will
be comfortable with well but see that's
assuming and this is the sort of the
last piece that is kind of the part that
kind of broken my brain as I've been
watching some of these guys talk about
it um I've just always had this
assumption that we're going to be able
to control it like like we can decide
because we made it that it's like your
kids like we can make a decision that we
only want it to be for our benefit and
we only want it to do things that are
good for people
and again A lot of people are
saying and this is a debate that I can't
even participate in because I'm I'm not
smart enough to understand how to have a
have a perspective I'm just explaining
what's being said there's a lot of
people who are saying first of all uh
it's a hopeless thing to try to control
it like you're not going to be able to
control it like the moment that we have
this intersection of the physical and
the digital and that and those brains
are super intelligent there's you're not
you're just going to have to hope that
they decide that humans
are worth
protecting uh but they're not really
going to have any like sense of
gratitude because they're not people
right there's going to be like they're
going to again that's where it goes back
to this like the laws of physics are the
things that will will drive all of it so
I I don't even know what that will look
like um but the analogy is like okay
we developed this incredible technology
that is about to be able to do things
that we can't even really imagine and we
can't even really Envision how we will
interact with them like the little
childish examples that we've given in
this podcast so far are just that
childish uninformed just two guys who
are just making things up we don't know
what it's going to actually be like it's
just our best guess to do something
right
um the aidea that we're going to be able
to use it in all these different ways
and and make it work for our benefit is
like you have a child and you just
expect that child is going to be your
child and do your bidding for the rest
of your life when the right thing to do
as a parent is to be like well you raise
it up and then you let it go off and do
its do its own thing that's what being a
great parent is and so there's a there's
a movement within this um Within These
these experts this that are saying that
listen the the right thing to to do is
to like we've created it we got to this
inevitable intersection of tech
technological advancement and now we
give we pass the Baton of control off to
this thing that we
created and because that's what a good
parent would do obviously not a Perfect
Analogy very dystopian very scary but I
think the argument that's being made is
guys it's kind of inevitable because you
can continue to try to control it but
how well does it go when you try to
control your adult kids how well does
that go how well how how well does
trying to control your college age kids
go get them to do what you want I'm not
going to answer that and
so what are we up against I don't know
and again this idea of sounds like fun
yeah let's get hope back in well the
hopeful thing is that like everything
that you don't want to
do and everything that you don't want to
put any effort into or any brain power
into you're not going to have to and
you're going to be left
with uh just like an existence of human
interaction and expression like like uh
a civilization that is designed
exclusively for human flourishing and
has every tool that it could possibly
ever need in order to guarantee that
that would be the hopeful that would be
the hopeful outcome so like no disease
and uh optimized health and
relationships and activities and like
not not [__] happiness not because
we know the stuff that makes people
happy right like money doesn't make
people happy getting to do all the stuff
that you want to do doesn't make you
happy but like meaning purpose
relationships these are the things that
make you happy and if that's true and
the machines can help with that then
they can bring bring about those
outcomes they can help us bring about
those
outcomes of course there's a lot of ways
that it could Veer off and go very very
bad for me it's not about being hopeful
or pessimistic but being curious and
engaged I think that's the best I can do
is that like if I'm not curious and
engaged at any level then I'm just I'm
checking out and I don't think that I
don't want to be that person so I I have
this
um instinct to just say oh this is
complicated and this is a bunch of
conjecture and I don't have any control
over it
anyway um
but even though that may be true I it's
going to it's going to impact my life so
I want to not only be informed but be
curious I mean it it's also an
exciting time to be alive to say there's
so much changing so quickly that we can
actually see it you know it's like
watching a time lapse it's like wow
that's how a flower
develops so I'm trying to adopt some of
that Curiosity to stay engaged um you
know keeping keeping my brain pliable
that's that's the best I can do but not
on the toilet not on the toilet not
happening on the toilet so that's that's
where I leave you um I'll leave you with
my wreck oh it's your wreck but I have
to I have to I have to make I have to
make this wreck you can wreck just
because if you want to hear hear there's
first of all there's lots of people
talking about this on the internet who
actually know what they're talking about
I strongly encourage you if you're
interested to move Beyond a couple of uh
hey hey internet boys no don't draw me
into this where's your W uh there's a
guy David Shapiro who he's a professor I
somewhere I don't know I think he's a
professor
um but he uh he just kind of like he's
kind of taken off in the past year
because and it's I mean it's uh it's got
a couple hundred thousand subscribers I
guess but it's pretty dry in terms of
just like okay I'm going to just be here
in the bottom of the corner his name on
YouTube yeah if you just search David
Shapiro and then he'll come up and he's
got like a he looks like uh peard he's
got like a Star Trek thing
um he'll kind of like if you want to sit
down and like watch somebody essentially
go through a 45 minute PowerPoint
presentation on different aspects of
this it's a way to stay again this is
for the people who are actually like
this kind of information is a fun thing
to learn about right I'll just like put
it on while I'm working out just to kind
of be like all right I'm going to see
how much of this I can understand and I
get a certain percentage of it uh but
he's got a really interesting
perspective in some of those analogies
about like the the the letting the kids
go and do their own thing it got from
him um but I think that he can there's
very practical things
like I think the most practical concern
for most people is what's this going to
do to the economy and like how many jobs
are going to get replaced right like we
didn't even talk about that but we could
very very quickly it makes a whole lot
of sense something people can understand
have a lot of jobs that are not needed
anymore and we currently set up in a
system where if 30 to 40% of people are
not working we have societal collapse
like we we can't have a society that
works like that let's keep it positive
we're wrapping things up um and so he
can kind of help you understand like
well that may not happen because of of
this or like here are some things that
we can think about but yeah I think your
point of like not just kind of just
sitting there letting it happen to you
but actually being as informed as you
can about it having like an opinion
because here's the one thing not as
informed as I can here's the one curious
and engaged to say this because it
really it really hit me hard I was uh
watching one of his videos and I spent
this time kind of like again like this
this combination of like Terror and
excitement which is the only way I can
describe it's like being a every roller
coaster it's like being on a roller
coaster
right um except you might
die and so I'll be watching these videos
and I'm like my mind is being blown and
then I was like okay I'm going to look
at some of the I don't know why put
myself through this I'm going to look at
some of the highlights from the
Republican presidential debate right
like somebody's analysis of it and uh
and then I like saw like five minutes of
these people talking back and forth to
each other and I was like it's so ironic
to like be thinking about a potentially
super intelligent AI or even just a
pretty smart one that can answer all
these questions and then turn to the
system of government that we have where
these people are are arguing with each
other so one of them can be in charge of
all of us and it just seems crazy that I
can just turn to chat GPT right now and
get a more informed opinion about more
things than any of these people could
come up with on their own right and like
something these two lines do not meet
this idea that we can just have this the
point I'm making is that the people
don't have the [__] figured out man and
like you think about the people who are
actually leading us like think about
Congress do you see whenever they start
asking questions about Facebook do you
see how uninformed they seem think about
them trying to figure this [__] out and
come up with legislation that somehow
serves as a guide like we are in for it
like I something crazy is going to
happen I I don't know if it's good or
bad but something crazy is about to
happen Okay I don't disagree uh hey man
just put put your phone down get in bed
put your phone over there get into bed
just take a d Shapiro take a little
night night watch some his it's night
night time R it's time for you to take a
live maybe this is why I've been waking
up at 4:00 a.m. every single night maybe
so dude yep for the past like month
coated in pee like wake up and like full
I'm fully awake
yeah
well Happy New Year Happy New Year
oh gosh we'll talk at you next week
uh oh yep yep # earbiscuits be a part of
the conversation you can always call us
1888 earpod
[Music]
one hey R link my name is Macy and I'm
from Southern California I'm just now
listening to your top 10 moments of
20123 and as of today I wanted to share
mine I just delivered a baby I wasn't
pregnant I uh I just work on an
ambulance and I work 911 calls and it
was amazing it was life altering and
anyways I hope you guys have a wonderful
day and hopefully you'll hear this
anyways bye love
you